[音楽]
今日すごくいい天気でしたね
今から僕は天気の話をしていきます
天気といってもこっちの鉄器
人生の転機の話す
たぶん皆さんもこれまで何度か人生の転機を経験されていると思います
でも自分の人生の転機って意外と少ないんですね
僕たち自分の人生の転機よりも他人の人生の転機と関わる回数の方が圧倒的に多いん
です
例えば子供の入学や卒業友達の引越しや同僚の結婚などなので今日僕は実際に携わった
2人の人生の転機を紹介しながら
他人の人生の転機との関わり方について話をしていきます
まず1人目は
めぐ
僕が彼女に会った当時彼女は大学で栄養士になるための勉強していました
順調に栄養士の資格を取得して
大学を卒業し就職をして働き始めます
ただ働き始めて3ヶ月が経った頃に相談のメールが来ました
お仕事のことで少し相談したいんですがお時間ありますかと僕はすぐに時間を空けて
彼女と会うことにしました
そこで彼女が話していた内容をざっとまとめるとこんな感じです
就職をしたら想像と違った今の仕事はやりたいことじゃない
辞めた後どうしたらいいかわからないとそんなに珍しい悩みじゃないですよね
たぶんこの中にも同じような悩みを相談された方や今同じ悩み抱えている方もいるかも
しれません
さてああ
どうしましょう
当時の彼女の要素だとそれ以上同じ仕事続けるのは少し精神的に無理だろうなという
感じでした
もう少し深く話を聞いていくと
明らかにですね彼女の表情が明るくなる瞬間があるんですね
それはカメラの話をしている時でした
聞けば親戚に買ってもらったデジカメで毎日自分がとってごはんの写真を撮っていると
しかも好きなん写真は aa に見ていられるしカメラのことはどれだけ考えても飽き
ない
そんなに好きなんだったら
カメラを仕事にしてしまおうと
は当時彼女が一眼レフカメラすら持っていなかったので僕が持っていたカメラを
プレゼントしました
そして約束をして前に最高の写真を撮り続けよう
具体的に言うと彼女が1日かけて撮影した沢山の写真からベストの一枚を北に送ってき
ます
僕はその写真に対して具体的なフィードバックをして web に毎日1枚ずつ公開し
ていく
この作業僕たち2人は100日間続けました
100日間毎日続けるといろいろ見えてきますね
特に彼女の場合明らかにわかってきたのは気持ちのノール写真と乗らない写真がすごく
はっきりしているんです
これは当時彼女が撮影した写真なんですが
この職や人をテーマにした写真
これはものすごくいいいい写真を撮るんです
でも一方
風景や建物をテーマにした写真
これは僕の心にあまり響かなかったんですね
ただこれは僕だけじゃなくて撮影する彼女自身もまったく同じことを感じていました
なのでこの時点で
苦手な写真は捨てて得意な食と人の写真だけで勝負をしていこうと決めました
ただプロトスてやっていくなら好き嫌いなんか言ってちゃダメなんじゃないと思う方も
いるかもしれませんが僕は本当に好きな事を一つ極めることができたらプロとして十分
やっていけると考えています
特にそれがその人の時間人生の時間すべてを費やせるほど好きである
没頭できるものである場合その可能性は圧倒的に高い
と思います彼女にとって写真は
すべての時間を費やせるものでした
そして100日の取組が終わる頃には彼女のオリジナルの撮影スタイルが完成したん
です
皆さん家族の写真と思い浮かびます
おうちの中で撮った写真って
ほとんどお父さんかお母さんが通るので子供ばっかり映ってるんですね
一方外で撮った写真は行事会記念日がすごく多いので少し着飾った写真が多いんです
でも本当に残す大家族の姿って子供を見つめるお母さんのこの自然な眼差しだったり
つまみ食いはしているところだったり家族で食卓を囲んでいる
こんな当たり前の風景なんじゃないかと思うんです
フォトグラファーのメグが自宅に実際にお邪魔をしてその過程の当たり前の日常記録に
残す
食卓写真というプロジェクトが誕生しました
沢山の過程の撮影をさせて頂く中で
こちらのご家族から撮影の半年後にお手紙をいただきました
先月
母が病気で亡くなりました
あの時の写真はまさに母と私たちが一緒に過ごした日常の証で
きっとこの先もずっと母との思い出を鮮明によみがえらせてくれることと思います
病気が発覚しもう限られた時間しか過ごせないとわかった時にすぐあの時撮影して
もらって本当に良かったと思いました
改めてありがとう
この手紙を受け取って
奥留め具は食卓写真を始めた意味があったなと感じました
それから二年がたち
メグはいま日本各地に加えて海外からも声がかかる
フォトグラファーになりました
そして2人目は工藤雅奇
僕が出会った当時彼は鍼治療の専門学校に通っていました
恋愛のきっかけは僕が解散した体のワークショップに彼が参加してくれたことが始まり
だったんですが彼は友達に連れてこられただけで全然乗り気じゃなかったんですね
なんかでワークショップ自体は半年続くすごく長いものだったんですが最初の方から
全然口をきいてくれなかったんです
それがですね
出会って2ヶ月もする頃に2人きりで食事をすることになりました
その時のことを今でもはっきり覚えています
注文した食事が運ばれてきて僕が食べようとしたら
珍しく彼のほうから口を開いたんですね
なんといったと思います
僕堂島さんのこと苦手ですって言ったんですよ
普通寝たくないのは入ってに言わないですよねこういうこと
たさあ彼はコって本音を初めて打ち明けてくれたところから僕と彼の距離は一気に近く
なりました
それからいろんな話をしていくと実は彼は口下手なだけでものすごく物事をよく観察し
ているし深く考えていると
なのでもしかしたら彼はぴったりな表現方法を一つ見つかったらものすごい面白い人間
になるんじゃないかとそう感じたんです
とはいえいきなり君には表現力が足りないからこれをやりなさいと言われたところ人は
やらないですよね
たぶんこういう時はその人の興味あるところから攻めていくとうまくいく気がします
当時の彼の好奇心が最も刺激されるキーワードはアフリカでした
じゃあ振り家事に会いに行こうと
ちょうどそのタイミングで
世界中のボーイスカウトの子どもたちが集まる世界ジャンボリーというイベントが日本
で開催されることを知りました
そこには約3万人を超える世界中の子どもが集まります
しかも鍼灸師のボランティアスタッフを募集していたんです
完璧なタイミングでした
僕と工藤君はすぐに横暴して1週間
世界各地から来た子どもたちにハリと呼吸をしました
ここでの体験は本当に素晴らしいものだったんですがそれ以上に最高の出会いがあり
ました
それは一緒にボランティアスタッフとして参加した鍼灸師のメンバーです
ボランティアといってもそれぞれが世界各国で開業して日本に帰ってきたような
日本人鍼灸師のオールスターのような人々でした
日中のボランティアは彼らと一緒に
世界中の子供たちにはりやお灸をして夜はみんなでご飯を食べます
その時に世界中の話をしてくれるんですね僕もすごくテンションがあります上がりまし
た
もちろん工藤君もどんどんテンションが上がってきて珍しく自分から夢を語り出すん
です
僕は30歳になったら必ずアフリカに行きたいんですって
多分工藤君は若いのにすごいねって言葉を期待したと思うんですよ
でも経験積んでる人は甘くなかったですね
彼が30歳になったらアフリカにいたいんですって言ったらあ
なんでライナーいかないと
何先延ばしにしているとから怒られ始めたんですね
そして怒られて追いつめられた彼はもうその場で
宣言をさせられました雷電の誕生日に北アフリカに行きますと
理由はどうあれ人間はやっぱり決めると強いですね
彼は本当に宣言通りよくと青の誕生日にアフリカのケニアに旅立ちました
そしてケニアではたくさん友達作ってボランティアでマッサージして海外での初めての
生活をすごく楽しんでたみたいです
ところがですね
ある日街の atm でお金をおろして外に出たら
知らないアフリカ人4人組に手足担がれて車で連れ去られたんですね
家族誘拐されました
そのままは知らないところを連れてかれて有り金全部取られて
でも何も抵抗しなかったらしいので
無事だったらしいんですよ
怖いですよね本当にただその出来事が彼の人生にものすごく大きい影響を与えたんです
かれそこからお金がもうないので貧しい村に寝泊まりしてたらしいですそこでは雨水を
飲むような暮らしをしていたらしいんですが
そこで出会った子の子供たち
彼らの笑顔が本当に貧しかったみたいで
ただ村が貧しすぎるので遠征状態が悪い
なのでこの子どもたちが毎年てどんどんどんどん病気でなくなるらしいんですね
彼は生まれて初めて子どもが大人になることすらできないという環境を目の当たりにし
ました
そこで自分は今何ができるんだろうと考え始めたんです
今もまだその答えは見つかっていません
でも彼はこれから自分の手でその答えを見つけていくと思います
日本に帰ってきた工藤君は本当にたくましい人間になってました
当時からは考えられないくらい堂々とコミュニケーションを取りますしもう僕のこと
苦手じゃないらしいです
そんな彼はですね今何をやっているかと言うと
外国で針を刺したり
グアテマラの湖でジャンプしたいん
渋谷で馬の散歩をしています
いったい何をやっているんだろうと思うかもしれませんが確実に言えるのは彼の人生は
めちゃくちゃ楽しそうだってことですこれすごく大事なことだと思います
ここまで2人の人生の転機を紹介してきましたがおそらくみなさんもこれからたくさん
の人の人生の転機と関わると思うんです
なのでその時に役立ちそうなポイント3つ簡単にまとめました
一つ目は全長に気づく
全長というのは変化が起こる前の小さな変化のことをいいます
全長は仕草や言葉や環境様々なところに表れます
ただこの全長だけを見つけるというのはすごく難しいです
なぜなら変化というのは変化する前の状態と後の状態これを比較して初めてわかるから
です
なので全長に気づくために大切なのはその人の日常をよく知ること
その人が普段どんなことをして何を考えているのかこれをしっかり観察していれば少し
の変化に気づくことができます
人生の転機の前には必ず前兆が存在します
二つ目
道筋に火をともす
人は遠くにある憧れや目標はすごく眩しく見えるんです
でもそこまでの行き方がわからないからどうしても一歩目を踏み出せません
だったらその道筋を僕らが照らすてあげたらいいと思います
例えばめぐの場合
毎日送ってくる写真に対して具体的なフィードバックをすることで一歩ずつ前に進め
ました
工藤君の場合は世界の入り口まで連れていったらそこからも一人で自由に歩き出しまし
た
決して背中を押し続けるわけではありません
僕たちはたまたま人生で今日もそうです
人生の途中でたまたま出会っただけなんですなので最後まで一緒に歩き続けるわけでは
ありません
いつかは枯れるということを前提に彼らの道筋に火を灯します
最後3つ目は理由を作る
自分の変化したいという気持ちに気づいて目の前の道が照らされたとしてもそれでも
まだ一歩を踏み出せない人はたくさんいます
だったら理由を作っちゃいましょう
でもそれは世界平和みたいなそんな大袈裟が理由じゃなくていいと思います
恵体に写真が好きだという強い思いから始まることもあれば功徳みたいに無理やり弱さ
れた日にちが理由になるということもありえます
それでも一般のへ踏み出さの強かったら
1本目で失敗しても大丈夫なんですよ2本目で修正すれば
2本目で失敗したら3本目で修正すれば大丈夫
もし全く理由が見つからないんだとしたら
あなたが理由になってあげてください
たぶん皆さんもあの人がいたから頑張れたっていうことあると思うんですよ
誰かにとってのあの人はあなたかもしれません
最後になりますが僕の本業お仕事は治療家です
病気やケガを治すのが仕事なんですね
なので写真やアフリカは本当は関係ないんですよ
なのになんで僕はわざわざ自分から首を突っ込んでこんな事をやってるんだろうと
改めて考えました
考えてわかったのはですね
僕はただ彼らの成長を見てニヤニヤしたいんですね
もちろんみんなが偉大な人物になってくれたらそれは凄く嬉しいことなんですけど
普通ののんびりした人生も僕はなかなかいいと思うんですよ
なのでそれぞれが自分らしい生き方を見つけてくれたら最高かなと思っています
それに自分から首突っ込むことで僕自身の人生が豊かになっていることは確かです
今日
本当にいい天気ですよね
ありがとうございました
[拍手]